polit poker in thüringen die linke will
eine cdu-frau als übergangs
ministerpräsident in die cdu reagiert
mit eigenen forderungen überraschung im
rennen um den parteivorsitz norbert
röttgen wirft als erster cdu kandidat
offiziell seinen hut in den ring und
erfolg bei der biathlon-wm vanessa hinz
stimmt im einzel zu silber und sichert
damit die zweite medaille für
deutschland ist
die vize-weltmeisterin bis jetzt
verdammt geil
die nachrichten nicht da es heute mit
christian sievert in allen heute um 7
wir gucken auf diesen nachrichten
dienstag und den sport hat kristin otto
in billerbeck und eine neue runde heute
in der thüringer regierungskrise und
viel taktik damit beginnen wir bodo
ramelow
der ex-ministerpräsident von der linken
hat alle überrascht mit einem neuen
schachzug
er schlägt vor dass christine
lieberknecht übergangs
ministerpräsidentin wird 70 tage lang
bis zu neuwahlen lieberknecht ist
ramelow vorgängerin und sie ist in der
cdu für die bringt der ramelow vorschlag
einiges an kopfzerbrechen und dann eine
erste reaktion ja aber aus erfurt
berichtet daniela sonntag
der redebedarf war riesig stunden
diskutierte die cdu fraktion im
thüringer landtag über die idee von bodo
ramelow die ehemalige
ministerpräsidentin christine
lieberknecht als übergangsregierungschef
zu reaktivieren grundsätzlich ein guter
personalvorschlag heißt es jetzt aber
nicht mit schnellen neuwahlen uns ist
stabilität für thüringen richtig und um
diese stabilität zu erreichen sehen wir
dass der vorschlag von bodo ramelow zu
kurz greift wir brauchen für diese
stabilität der regierung des übergangs
und wir finden um diese stabilität zu
erreichen braucht es eine regierung die
vollständig besetzt und
parteiübergreifend von berufenen
experten gestellt wird
erst eine regierung mit lieberknecht an
der spitze wählen dann der haushalt
später in ruhe neuwahlen die cdu will
sich zeit verschaffen spielt den ball
zurück an die linke die würden am
liebsten ganz schnell neu wählen sahen
sich nach ihrer fraktionssitzung
vormittags schon im wahlkampf
es bleibt dabei wir sind bereit ihre
wege zu gehen
auch uns selbst zurückzunehmen aber es
ist auch klar bodo ramelow bleibt unsere
ministerpräsidenten kandidat und wir
sehen uns eigentlich jetzt schon im
wahlkampf ohne die cdu stimmen aber ist
eine parlamentsauflösung nicht möglich
auch der geschäftsführende
ministerpräsident kemmerich von der fdp
macht eine kehrtwende
besser jetzt keine neuwahlen sagte er
heute nach einer sitzung des
ältestenrates die verhandlungen im
landtag sollen heute abend weitergehen
ausgang ungewiss und geber live nach
erfurt zu lande hat melanie guten abend
wie groß ist denn diese zwickmühle in
der die thüringer cdu da steckt ja also
diese zwickmühle scheint groß zu sein
zum einen spricht ja mike mohring eben
von jener stabilität die es braucht und
diese stabilität braucht eben doch zeit
die cdu sagt wir wollen den haushalt für
das kommende jahr durch bringen und das
schafft man eben nicht mit einer
kurzfristigen regierung sowie es bodo
ramelow vorschlägt es brauche zeit das
muss durch parlament gebracht werden und
gleichzeitig sagte mike mohring vorhin
auch was solle sich denn an den
verhältnissen ändern wenn es neuwahlen
geben und zudem muss man einfach sehen
seit der wahl thomas kemmerich es ist
sind eben die zahlen auch für die cdu
gesunken sie haben müssen verluste
hinnehmen
und natürlich befürchten sie damit
natürlich auch bei einer neuwahl
stimmenverluste und das hieße eben auch
weniger mandate im landtag das versucht
die cdu zu vermeiden sie spielt deshalb
eben auch auf zeit und hier hinter mir
hinter der tür wird es wieder eine neue
sitzung geben mit den linken der spd den
grünen und der cdu so wie gestern abend
um 20 uhr geht's los und dann wird bodo
ramelow darauf reagieren was die cdu
heute gesagt es geht also weiter melanie
haack erfurt herzlichen dank
im bund bleibt dass bewerber rennen um
den cdu-parteivorsitz spannend und auch
einigermaßen ungeordnet heute überrascht
der cdu-außenpolitiker norbert röttgen
mit der ansage er wolle cdu-chef werden
röttgen ist damit der erste der das ganz
offiziell tut und macht den herren
konkurrenz die bereits als kandidaten
gehandelt werden
armin laschet jens spahn und friedrich
merz wie röttgen allesamt aus nordrhein
westfalen die noch vorsitzende hat heute
begonnen mit ihnen drei um gespräche zu
führen mathis feldhoff berichtet er will
cdu-vorsitzender werden norbert röttgen
ist der erste der das öffentlich
verkündet seine kandidatur ist wohl auch
als kritik am zögern der möglichen
kandidaten sparen märz und lasche zu
verstehen die würden zu viel über taktik
und zu wenig über inhalte reden davon
habe ich seit der rückzugsankündigung
von annegret kramp karrenbauer wenig
gehört und darum kandidiere ich am
wochenende hatte er auf der
sicherheitskonferenz intensiv mit der
parteivorsitzenden geredet aber
offensichtlich ohne von seiner absicht
zu berichten die kommt heute morgen per
mail
roetgen gilt lange als merkels liebling
unter ihr war er geschäftsführer der
fraktion später umweltminister 2010
gewinnt er gegen armin laschet die
ministerpräsidenten kandidatur in nrw
die wahl 2012 verliert er kracht als
röttgen sich weigert als
oppositionsführer nach nrw zu gehen
entscheidet sich merkel das erste und
einzige mal dazu einen ihrer minister
raus zu schmeißen um so in diesem abend
einen personellen neuanfang möglich zu
machen
parteiintern gilt seine heutige
kandidatur als er chancenlos aber die
idee ein team im hinterzimmer zusammen
zu stellen ist wohl erledigt und darum
ist glaube ich das team an dieser stelle
im moment er sozusagen eine taktik oder
ein ansatz wie man interessen einzelner
unter einen hut bringt damit es keinen
er gibt und alles ruhig bleibt am mittag
fährt ein anderer möglicher kandidat aus
der cdu-zentrale friedrich merz war zum
gespräch bei der parteivorsitzenden
ob er dabei seine kandidatur erklärt hat
ist nicht bekannt
ja noch in westfalen bislang sehr gut
vertreten man kann auch sagen
ausschließlich vertreten
fragen wir theo koll theo guten namen
plattform im beitrag gehört die chancen
von norbert röttgen seien nicht so gut
warum nämlich nur wenn man sich einer
cdu umhört dann sind die chancen
wirklich eher gering jedenfalls momentan
unter diesen klassischen kriterien in
der cdu wie sogenannte hausmacht oder
wer hat einen großen landesverband
hinter sich aber er könnte durchaus
jemand sein der einen breiten konsens
erzeugen kann er hat sich in der
vergangenheit nicht gescheut auch gegen
die kanzlerin klare kante zu zeigen und
gleichzeitig ist er bei der eher
liberaler weltoffener kandidat der seine
bewerbung heute sehr klar inhaltlich
begründet hat und dennoch hat der
aktuell eher außenseiterchancen
da guckt man auch mal so ein bisschen
auf den zeitrahmen im moment läuft alles
relativ ungeordnet wann kommt in den
prozess denn ein bisschen klarheit rein
nun wir werden ausgerechnet am karnevals
montag ein wenig mehr erfahren über den
weiteren prozess frau kramp karrenbauer
spricht ja in dieser woche heute mit
märz insgesamt mit dem triumvirat der
möglichen bewerber also laschet märz
sparen und zusätzlich natürlich jetzt
mit dem sicheren bewerber röttgen
in gewisser weise hatte röttgen das
bisherige mikado spiel der drei anderen
durchgeschüttelt er hat sich einfach
bewegt und damit ist das bisherige
hinterzimmer verfahren einer teamlösung
nicht mehr realistisch wobei man muss
sagen diese sogenannte teamlösung von
der ja alle gesprochen haben
die hat ja immer nur bedeutet ich werde
chef und die anderen ort und sich dann
bitte im team unter das ist jetzt vorbei
viele fragen sind aber noch offen
herzlichen dank theo vier anwärter auf
den chefposten der cdu wer macht das
rennen zur kandidatensuche gibt es viele
weitere infos auf heute.de unter anderem
ein porträt von norbert röttgen und
außerdem bewerten zwei
politikwissenschaftler die chancen der
anderen drei bisher gehandelten
kandidaten
unser nächstes thema heute abend in
china hinterlässt das corona virus immer
tiefere spuren in der wirtschaft mit
apple hat jetzt erstmals ein weltkonzern
seine geschäftsziele gestützt
die umsatzziele für das laufende quartal
seien nicht mehr zu schaffen
inzwischen zählt die offizielle
chinesische statistik gut 72.000
krankheitsfälle
die zahl der toten stieg auf fast 1900
und darunter ist auch der direktor einer
klinik in der provinzhauptstadt wo hahn
dem ort wo alles begann ulf röller im
chinesischen staatsfernsehen erlebt die
nation ein drama mit der arzt doktor leo
kemming stirbt am corona virus in diesem
zimmer liegt der direktor des
krankenhauses sagte die reporterin
doktor leo timing war ein prominenter
arzt in woran der sich ende januar bei
der arbeit infiziert hatte nur noch die
medizinischen geräte halten ihn am leben
erfahren wir um 10.30 ist er heute
gestorben
bisher haben sich mehr als 1700 ärzte
infiziert aus dem ganzen land schickt
die kommunistische partei medizinisches
personal nachbarn und den nachschub zu
sichern
der kampf gegen das virus als
patriotische pflicht
[Musik]
in offiziellen statistiken zeigt die
chinesische gesundheitsbehörde
dass die ansteckungszahlen sich
abschwächen solche trends können sich
ändern wenn neue bevölkerungsgruppen
sich anstecken es ist zu früh zu sagen
ob dieser abwärtstrend weitergeht
das virus schwächt immer mehr die
wirtschaft chinas und der welt der
technologiegigant apple fürchtet
zulieferung engpässe und senkte seine
umsatzprognose
die lage ist immer noch sehr angespannt
es wird lange dauern bis alles wieder
normal ist
viele mögliche kunden sind zu hause
eingeschlossen wer etwas braucht muss
die örtliche behörde anrufen die liefert
dann aber nur das nötigste
die syrische regierung bombardiert
weiter den norden des eigenen landes und
die uno kritisiert dass jetzt scharf und
fordert es soll korridore geben durch
die flüchtende zivilisten sicher
passieren könnten
in den flüchtlingscamps ist die lage
verheerend sagt die uno besonders kinder
leiden unter hunger krankheiten und der
eisigen kälte
die syrische regierung kohl ihre
verbündeten russland und iran versuchen
mit der militärischen offensive gebiete
im norden des landes von rebellen
zurückzuerobern
in der türkei lassen heute zwei
nachrichten aufhorchen zum einen
landesweite razzien gegen mutmaßliche
gülen anhänger mit mehr als 180
festnahmen
die türkische führung macht den prediger
und seine bewegung für den putschversuch
im sommer 2016 verantwortlich und zum
anderen eine überraschende wende im
sogenannten g sie prozess ein gericht
spricht den bürgerrechtler osman kavala
von allen terror vorwürfen frei aus
istanbul berichtet jörg brase mit
freispruch hatten die meisten nicht
gerechnet freunde und unterstützer der
angeklagten jubelten nach dem urteil
lebenslänglich hatte der staatsanwalt
gefordert für die meisten beobachter
waren die vorwürfe konstruiert das
verfahren von anfang an ein witz am ende
wurde
eine gruppe die aber nicht eine
raffinierte comedia sondern fast
ähnliche ganze ganzes nicht raffiniert
also höchstwahrscheinlich zwischenzeit
hat der richter mit jemandem telefoniert
der industriellen und kunstmäzen osman
kavala so der vorwurf aber einen
umsturzversuch geplant damals 2013 im
istanbul ag sie park was als kritik an
der abholzung einiger bäume begann wuchs
zu den größten regierungskritischen
protesten in der türkei bei den istanbul
protesten machen wir alle jung bis alt
ich war 15 tage mit meiner tochter da
man kann niemanden verurteilen weil er
damals bei den protesten mitgemacht hat
die unterstützer der gesi angeklagten
sind glücklich über das ende eines
prozesses der in ganz europa heftig
kritisiert wurde ausmann kavala ein
bekanntes gesicht hatte die
unterstützung der europäischen politik
und medien viele andere inhaftierte aber
haben diese unterstützung nicht das
urteil gibt hoffnung aber einen wechsel
der türkischen rechtssprechungen politik
bedeutet es noch nicht heute gab es
fahndungs befehle gegen 700 mutmaßliche
anhänger der gülen-bewegung die für den
putschversuch von 2016 verantwortlich
gemacht wird die verhaftungswelle gegen
regime-gegner rollt weiter und jetzt das
große thema mobilität und umwelt da gilt
carsharing als vielversprechendes modell
für die zukunft wird auf jeden fall
immer beliebter
mehr als 25.000 fahrzeuge werden aktuell
auf deutschen straßen geteilt gut 5000
mehr als noch vor einem jahr
aus ökologischer sicht könnte das eine
gute idee sein die nutzer verzichten
aufs eigene auto insgesamt sind damit
weniger fahrzeuge unterwegs aber ist das
tatsächlich so
oder heißt carsharing unterm strich
nicht einfach nur noch mehr autos über
die entwicklung und die probleme der
branche hans-jürgen das
carsharing-angebot in großstädten ist
deutlich gewachsen
kaum eine innenstadt straße an der keine
leihwagen auf kunden warten aktuell sind
es über 25.000 nochmal fast
22 prozent mehr als im vorjahr das
carsharing ist immer noch ein kleiner
markt den man auch als nische bezeichnen
kann
aber es wächst seit jahren und das ist
auch dieses jahr wieder gewachsen also
wir haben 100 orte zusätzlich mit einem
car sharing angebot insgesamt sind es
jetzt 840 orte je mehr geteilte autos
desto weniger straßenverkehr so die
carsharing grundidee
doch seit autokonzerne mit ihren
tochterfirmen zu den anbietern gehören
hat sich das geschäftsmodell verändert
das klassische stationäre carsharing mit
festen stellplatz und monatsbeitrag
nutzt heute nur noch eine minderheit
fast dreimal so viele sind kunden
station unabhängige angebote vor allem
in ballungszentren dabei können die
autos im stadtzentrum irgendwo am
straßenrand stehen gelassen werden wo
der nächste kunde sie dann per
smartphone app findet unklar ist ob
dieses modell tatsächlich zu weniger
stadtverkehr führt studien ergaben dass
station ungebundene carsharing system
bringt mit sich dass relativ viele
fahrzeuge in der fahrzeugflotte auf die
straße kommen also wissen einerseits
gibt es diese verlagerung weg vom
eigenen pkw aber andererseits kommen
ebenso viele neue fahrzeuge durch die
durch das system auf die straße
das eben dann im endeffekt mehr fahrzeug
auf der straße sind als zuvor
immerhin auch wenn kritiker in den
höheren anteil fordern elektrisch fährt
bereits fast jedes fünfte carsharing
fahrzeug so eine überwältigte sportlerin
haben wir schon ganz am anfang der
sendung gesehen jetzt gibt es mehr dazu
gehen von christian cooler spruch fast
hätte es zu gold gereicht doch nach 15km
fehlten 2,2 sekunden
vanessa hinz jubelte dennoch goldig über
ihre silbermedaille bei den
biathlon-weltmeisterschaften in antholz
und konnte ihren überraschenden erfolg
kaum fassen
überglücklich zufrieden vanessa hinz hat
nicht gold verloren sondern silber
gewonnen
sie müssen gar nicht wirklich klar
mitglieder immer nur es ist einfach so
unglaublich schöner dort hat die basis
für dieses gute rennen hier gutes
schießen nur beim letzten anschlag
stehend ein fehler insgesamt also 19
treffer bei 20 schuss dazu ihr enormer
kampfgeist auf der schlussrunde
sie kennt die richtzeit der zu diesem
zeitpunkt führenden norwegerinnen marco
holz bürohäuser land die zuschauer
tragen sie förmlich ins ziel
sie weiß eine medaille ist hier sicher
nur welche die weltmeisterin in der
verfolgung setzt auch heute im einzel
den goldenen schlusspunkt dorothea
wierer hauchdünne vorsprung 2,2 sekunden
von dem her ärgerlich mini zuseher
sondern ich habe damit gerechnet ich bin
die saison gar nicht auf dem podium
standen und jeder wünscht sich bei einer
wm zu stehen und ich denke dafür jedem
rennen ok es kann aber wirklich nur drei
oben stehen und bis jetzt nie von den
drei bänden ist schon geil
der größte erfolg in ihrer karriere die
27 jährige genießt dieses wunderbare
gefühl förmlich dorothea wierer aus
italien die beste marke als böse land
freut sich über ihre vierte medaille im
vierten rennen heute bronze ja nachher
fußball champions league achtelfinal
hinspiele und für thomas tuchel trainer
von paris an immer ein ganz spezieller
abend denn erstmalig kehrt er nach der
vorzeitigen trennung vom bvb nach
dortmund zurück als auswärts mannschaft
zu kommen ist natürlich eine riesen
herausforderung und wenn man zurück in
dieses stadion kommen wenn man zwei
jahre trainer war das ist natürlich für
mich besonders aber auch wenn es für sie
das vielleicht langweilig ist es geht am
ende nicht und mich persönlich sondern
wir kommen mit einer guten mannschaft
und voller vertrauen und nur einzelne
sind natürlich den sieg christi vielen
da erklären lässt intelli meldet gleich
regen und schnee sind unterwegs und der
kollege claus kleber informiert sie aber
21 uhr 45 im heute-journal morgen gibt
es wieder punkt 19 uhr bis dann aber
erstmal von und zahlen ihnen
sehr angenehm abend tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter in die kräftige
westliche strömung ist ein neues tief
eingelagert und dessen kaltfront wird
uns bis zum morgigen nachmittag und
abend dann überqueren und an den alpen
wird es längere zeit schneien sie sehen
es hier hinweis eingezeichnet schauen
wir erstmal in die nacht da kommen
wieder von westen viele wolken auf regen
und schnee und wieder bis etwa 500 meter
fällt der schnee ansonsten im osten und
im südosten da bleibt es trocken die
temperaturen sinken bis auf minus 2 grad
an den alpen und 5 grad zum beispiel an
der nordsee morgen am vormittag regnet
und schneit es im osten weiterhin wobei
der schnee in den bergen fällt ansonsten
an den alpen aber durchaus längere zeit
schneefall von westen her lockert es
dann am nachmittag auf und die sonne
zeigt sich sonst bleibt es durchwachsen
und weiterhin bis zum nachmittag schnee
an den alpen temperaturen dazu zwei grad
im vogtland und 9 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet schauen wir auf die
nächsten tage
am donnerstag wird es ruhig sein wir
haben norden etwas regen vier bis zwölf
grad teilweise sonnenschein im süden am
freitag im norden etwas regen 4 bis 12
und samstag bis 14 grad deutlich mehr
wind ein schöner abend